the ballroom was packed with a brand-new
slate of celebrities on Monday night who
were full of excitement I am ecstatic I
feel like I'm on cloud ride 9 right now
I see was like this bad broad who like
you know it's untouchable
but there was also plenty of emotion
dance has always been one of my biggest
insecurities and so many things that
I've gone through it's like you're so
afraid but like you can do it
what a beautiful opportunity to just be
able to really like work work through
this this fear and and to try to just
enjoy it all and embrace it and learn as
much as I can
Little Women LA star Tara Jolie was also
teary-eyed and I don't want anybody to
say like considering she's a little
person she did great I just want people
to say Tara did great end of discussion
this whole journey has been very
emotional as well as a rollercoaster of
energy tied at the top of the
leaderboard Laurie and her partner Val
Chmerkovskiy and James Hinchcliffe and
his partner Shauna Burgess at the bottom
Rick Perry and his pro Emma Slater